اخبار الكوارث الطبيعيه لا تتوقف افريقيا
القاره قد تنشطر الى نصفين هذا وفق تقرير
اعده باحثون بريطانيون ونشر في دوريه
جيوفسكي
لا داعي للفزع فهذا الامر قد يستغرق بين
خمسه الى عشره ملايين سنه والسبب هو
الزلازل التي ادت الى تصدعات في قشره
الارض اخرها الزلزال القوي الذي ضرب جنوب
تركيا وشمال سوريا وخلف نحو 50 الف قتيل
هذا الزلزال وصل التداعياته الى القاره
السمراء زلزال تركيا وسوريا وقع بين ثلاثه
صفائح تيكتونيه وتسبب في تحرك صفيحه
الاناضول ثلاثه امتار غربا وادى ايضا الى
تحرك الصفيحه الافريقيه وساهم في اتساع ما
يعرف بصدع الشرق افريقيا الذي اصبح اكثر
نشاطا مع تزايد الحركه مستمره داخل القشره
الارضيه الصدع يبلغ طوله سته وخمسين كيلو
مترا او 56 كيلومترا وظهر في الصحاري
الاثيوبيه في عام 2018 يمتد نشطه في شرق
افريقيا اسفل كل من اثيوبيا وكينيا
وتنزانيا حيث تشير دراسات الى ان تحركات
الصفائح قد بدات من منطقه عفر شمال
اثيوبيا وانتشرت جنوبا نحو زيمبابوي
وبمعدل يتراوح بين السنتيمترين ونصف الى
خمسه سنتيمترات سنويا هذا الامتداد يقع
فوق نقطه تقاطع ثلاث صفائح التكتونيه
تتقشر ببطء شديد وتنزلق بعيدا عن بعضها
البعض وهي عمليه جيولوجيه معقده يقول
العلماء بانها ستقسم القاره السمراء الى
قسمين ما يحدث في الصدع يمثل تماما الحركه
التي كونت البحر الاحمر ولكن بمعدل اكثر
بطئا وفقا ما نشر في دوريه
وخلص وخلص العلماء القائمون على الدراسه
الى ان تشكيل محيط جديد في افريقيا يمكن
ان يكون وهو امر مرجح وبعدها سيتقدم قاع
البحر على طول الصدى هنا ستصبح القره
الافريقيه اصغر حجما وستشكل جزيره كبيره
في المحيط الهندي تضم اجزاء من اثيوبيا
والصومال وكذا القرن الافريقي